ça
saint paul de vence entre vence une
carte postale de la france un rêve de
vacances pour les touristes le calme les
cigales la pétanque à lons
le homing entouré de ses amis et chinois
est très intrigués par ce jeu qui fait
attroupement
[Musique]
millionnaire il a fait fortune en chine
dans les télécommunications
et outre l'aspect pittoresque
c'est l'art contemporain qu'il intéresse
ici à saint pol
on trouve des dalits chagall et picasso
à tous les coins de rue
vacances dutil il est ici pour acheter
des oeuvres d'art l'art une passion
naissante chez les nouveaux riches sinon
je pense que vous les français la
culture de collectionner de belles
pièces d'art est imprégnée dans votre
esprit votre histoire
alors que nous les chinois nous sommes
que des débutants dans ce domaine nous
avons encore beaucoup de choses à
apprendre
pause déjeuner sous les oliviers à la
fin du repas au moment du thé lui au
mini raconte à ses amis ou deux jeune
galeriste qui l'accompagnent comment il
est devenu riche c'était il ya quinze
ans
[Musique]
jusqu'à aujourd'hui encore mal au dos
ça se passait à niang jeu transportaient
des barres de fer
j'étais différent des autres qui étaient
à l' usine
dès que le chef de chantier avait le dos
tourné ils arrêtaient de travailler
alors que moi j'étais là pour apprendre
la vraie vie
et il était hors de question de faire
comme eux
je travaillais sans arrêt
autodidacte il n'a jamais connu
d'université il a tenté travailler pour
une marque de textile sans succès mais à
cette époque il a rencontré beaucoup de
gens qui l'ont aidé à monter sa propre
entreprise de télécommunications
aujourd'hui il parcourt le monde dans
les plus beaux hôtels il y a quinze ans
il gagne à peine 4 euros par mois
la chine vivaient dans la pauvreté
et depuis l'ouverture du pays avec
l'étranger les opportunités s'offrent à
nous
il existe de plus en plus de jeunes
chinois qui sont dans la même situation
que moi
moi je ne suis qu'un parmi tant d'autres
[Musique]
à 8000 km en chine
pékin la capitale ici l'on vénère
toujours l'architecte de la révolution
prolétarienne
mao mordent depuis 30 ans
depuis l'ouverture économique du pays il
ya 15 ans le socialisme est
définitivement enterré le capitalisme
s'impose du otc building les grosses
berlines allemandes remplacent peu à peu
les vélos
dans sa voiture avec chauffeur nous
retrouvons le homing notre touristes
rencontrés à saint paul de vence
nous sommes en pleine semaine
aujourd'hui il ne va pas au bureau il
s'accorde du temps et profite
direction le toit d'un des plus beaux
hôtels de la ville huot ming n'a plus
besoin de travailler pour vivre alors ce
matin pour lui ces tennis
avec deux professeurs particuliers
mais vous avez le temps de voyager et de
faire du tennis
j'essaie de m'organiser et de garder du
temps pour faire du tennis indoor
vous n'avez pas trop de travail au
bureau
ce fait six mois que je ne suis plus
allé au bureau
en plein cours il prend même le temps
d'inviter des amis pour le thé pour eux
c'est dorénavant consommation et l'on
est fier d'étaler ses richesses
elle elle est riche elle est très riche
elle a beaucoup d'immobilier
elle a beaucoup de voitures de luxe
aussi des bmw des porsche
pour les millionnaires chinois c'est
farniente à l'occidentale
on a tous beaucoup de temps pour les
loisirs moi je n'ai pas d'amis stressé
[Musique]
mis à part le tennis tu fois par semaine
le homing passe le plus clair de son
temps à acheter des oeuvres d'art nous
le retrouvons dans son appartement aux
trente troisième étage d'un des plus
haut building de pékin c'est ici qu'ils
entreposent tous ses achats des artistes
contemporains chinois qui peuvent
aujourd'hui exprimer leur ressentiment
vis-à-vis du régime maoïste
[Musique]
ce tableau est fait par un jeune artiste
contemporain chinois qui s'appelle goni
ongles poutre où il ya tous ces
personnages ont une tête de cochon
regarder le livre rouge ou le ruban
rouge font référence à l'époque de la
révolution culturelle
est en réalité il veut dire que le
cerveau des chinois de l'époque
ressembler à celui des cochons
tableau récemment
à l'époque de mahmur il aurait le droit
de peindre ça on lui aurait coupé la
tête
des oeuvres souvent à plus de cent mille
euros et hugo ming est tellement riche
qu'il en achètent à tour de bras pour
nombre d'entre elles il ne peut même
plus en profiter
tout ce que vous voyez ici ce sont des
biens que j'ai achetés dans des ventes
aux enchères
et regardez je n'ai même plus de place
pour les exposer
et aujourd'hui sont 600 m² est trop
petit
alors il va déménager dans la banlieue
de pékin une banlieue cossue au milieu
d'autres millionnaires
il a demandé à ses amis de venir le
rejoindre pour leur faire visiter le
chantier de sa future maison
[Musique]
de quoi accrocher ses centaines de
toiles
ce n'est pas le chantier d'un immeuble
d'une usine d'un théâtre
juste de sa villa
1800 mètres carrés
[Musique]
c'est l'espace de jeux des enfants c'est
sur deux étages oui bon jouer comme ça
je vais installer un toboggan qui
partira de l'aïe qui descendra comme ça
là c'est une autre salle à manger c'est
suffisant non c'est trop grand
excusez moi il ya beaucoup de maisons
comme ça en chine
entre un peu oui oui très peu
du moins j'en ai jamais vu
le chantier a déjà commencé depuis un an
le luxe de hugo homing avoir le temps
d'attendre pour être sûr définition de
sa maison musée
et quand est ce que la maison sera
terminé l'année prochaine
je pense qu'il faudra encore six mois
vous êtes pressé non sûrement pas
le homing s'est construit à la force du
poignet ce n'est pas le cas de tout le
monde
en chine il existe déjà une jeune
génération dorée comme en occident dans
les magazines people une génération qui
profitent de la récente fortune de leurs
parents
celui qui est fier de nous montrer les
jouets derniers cris des enfants
habitent encore chez papa et maman
lanzaro à 32 ans son père est un riche
promoteur expose ses chantiers sur une
fresque peinte au milieu du salon
[Musique]
ce sont les maisons que l'on a construit
voyez ces maisons le sont toutes dans
mon village ça c'est ma maison la façade
sont toutes sortes de maisons toutes ces
maisons étaient construites par mon père
là il ya mon père ma mère et moi moi je
porte un livre et puis c'est ma soeur
aînée
zaho fait partie de la nouvelle jet set
pékinoise son père lui a payé des études
en australie de retour il travaille avec
lui mais il a du temps libre cet après
midi il part avec son chauffeur essayer
une voiture qui va très vite
[Musique]
vous aimez les voitures de sport j'aime
ça j'aime bien ça
mais j'ai un peu peur que ce ne soit pas
très adapté pour la ville la pêcherie
effectivement à pékin ac les bouchons en
permanence pourtant la dernière tendance
est dit posséder une voiture de sport
surpuissante zaho et tenté lui aussi la
chine est devenue le cinquième pays
acheteurs de ce genre de bijou tombe
bien 420 mille euros
simao n'a toléré aucune richesse
matérielle pendant 30 ans les choses ont
aujourd'hui bien changé
42 de ses bolides italiens ont été
vendus en chine l'année dernière
[Musique]
c'est à lui est sous le charme
celle là je pense qu'elle est bien tu es
salaam est chouette
décision est prise de l'essayer
[Musique]
comment vous vous sentez
moi je trouve ça un peu dangereux quand
même
j'ai eu l'impression de m'envoler
avant de prendre sa décision à eau a
convié deux amis chez le concessionnaire
quand on est jeune et riche on est
presque partout comme chez soi
voilà deux mannequins gagnante d'un
concours national de jumelles dont pékin
tellement jet set et var si j'avais
assez d'argent j'achèterai la rouge
mais si je ne peux dépenser que deux
cent mille euros alors je prends la
noire
et vous y pensez
la régie pense elle est très belle
après sa journée bien remplie zaho dean
dans le meilleur restaurant japonais de
pékin vous savez mes invités tous qu'ils
commandent boisson alcool
autour de la table star en devenir agent
producteur télé d'aizawa invité
également les deux jumelles mannequin de
l'après midi pour le dîner il a demandé
un salon privé et un cuisinier
particulier l'hôte est plutôt du genre
épicurien
tous les jours nous buvons jusqu'à
l'ivresse un jour on a vu jusqu'à 3
heures du matin et puis après on est
allé nager nu dans la piscine c'était
génial
et
la piscine au plein coeur de la nuit
dallas c'était quelque chose
la vie est définitivement fait pour
s'amuser
il ya tellement d'amis on se retrouve
ensemble on boit un coup on est contents
tous ensemble
clavier dur la semaine lundi au vendredi
je travaille dur avec mon père
et j'ai tellement projet il faut monter
une école et développer une université
or
il ya aussi cette histoire de club de
golf
que le week end je vois mes amis
dans les assiettes omar et une quinzaine
de plats qui suivent à la table on
trinque toutes les cinq minutes tu sais
qu tradition oblige saké japonais mais
aussi vins français mélange des cultures
comme dans les clubs branchés
occidentaux de new york los angeles ou
londres l'a fait à pékin pour yahoo et
ses amis c'est l'insouciance
jusqu'au bout de la nuit
ici à pékin malgré les souvenirs d'une
chine traditionnelle et cinq fois
millénaire la vie ressemble de plus en
plus à celle des américains ou des
européens à partir du moment où l'on a
de l'argent avec les mêmes problèmes
aussi bas au coin à 39 ans il a fait
fortune dans l'immobilier et la de quoi
contempler lorsqu'il regarde ses
maquettes
[Musique]
ceci est une maquette de notre parc
résidentiel
c'est un cabinet d'architecturé
américain qu'il a créé
mais nous l'avons amélioré avec des
critères chinois
et combien avez vous construit
d'appartement
peut-être bien 5000 à 6000 appartement
mais je suis plus fort en superficie
en dix ans il a construit plus d'un
million et demi de mètres carrés en
chine
mais aujourd'hui enfermé dans son bureau
il ne rêve que de nature
on se sent bien ainsi ses traits
campagne comme décor
les oiseaux viennent souvent ti jouer
alors tous les vendredis soirs comme un
citadins aisés d'une grandes capitales
occidentales
il fuit la pollution avec sa famille il
part à la campagne grâce à sa fortune il
a acheté un havre de paix à 40 km de
pékin à jampaling le petit saint-trop'
plus de deux hectares de verdure pour
préserver sa famille et une maison
d'architecte de 5000 m²
oh mais c'est monsieur deux ans qui joue
au piano
c'est lui qui a écrit ce morceau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
il m'a écrit cette mélodie au début de
notre rencontre
au coin et sa femme sont plutôt atypique
en chine
[Musique]
alors qu'une grande partie de la
population se demande comment remplir
son assiette et tentent de fuir les
campagnes pour la ville ici cm à
profusion et au petit déjeuner on mange
bio
la vie au centre-ville est assez
stressante
donc nous venons ici pour nous détendre
on peut faire plein de choses ici y
compris manger et boire de bonnes choses
par exemple ceci est du bon lait de
notre élevage la vache est dans notre
ferme on n'en trouve pas en ville
pour protéger ce bonheur des grilles et
des caméras tout le long
un réflexe ce singulier dans le pays et
le programme du week-end ressemble aux
activités d'un club de luxe artistiques
et sportives
mais il n'en a pas toujours été ainsi
pour eux
quand j'étais petit la vie était dure
pour ma famille
nous appartenions à la couche de
citadins pauvres nous sommes six enfants
dans ma famille et je suis le quatrième
et quelles étaient vos difficultés
les difficultés mon père était le
capitaine d'un bateau qui transportait
des passagers sur le fleuve yangtsé et
ma mère une ouvrière ordinaire
[Musique]
cela veut dire que le salaire de mes
parents était le seul revenu de la
famille en tout cela faisait six ou sept
euros par mois je tends pas
la même ville pas la même eu le temps
aujourd'hui bas au coin ne souhaite
consacrer sa fortune au cinéma
[Musique]
il possède déjà 800 salles dans le pays
plus une chez lui
il se lance dans la production d'un
nouveau format concurrent des dvd lever
des
même à la campagne et joint l'utile à
l'agréable
toujours dans le confort le plus absolu
[Musique]
il ya un rapport avec notre travail
ce produit fait partie de notre business
des familles
étant donné que mon mari a fait des
études de cinéma et que nos enfants
adorent les films et bien nous avons
créé cette salle de cinéma chez nous
c'est le plaisir de la famille
instants privilégiés et à chaque culture
ces préoccupations de parents
il faut que tu apprennes à faire du
cheval imagine qu'un jour tu te
retrouves dans une prairie et bien
falloir que tu saches en faire pour
survivre c'est comme savoir nager c'est
indispensable d'accord
regardez comme il est courageux
[Musique]
certains tentent de se préserver à la
campagne d'autres profitent du
développement de la ville
en vue des jo tk la fièvre un
gigantesque chantier la ville racé
quartier historique le prix des loyers
augmentent de 15% par an parmi ceux qui
veulent profiter de la manne chenil kun
il a fait fortune dans l'alimentaire
pour 2008 nous allons investir à pékin
le but est d'avoir plus de
77 restaurants
vous en avez combien aujourd'hui nous en
avons 19 aujourd'hui
et en 2008
de plus nous allons assurer le repas
pendant les jo au total ça fait plus de
180 mille repas par jour
il se veut résolument moderne et pour
séduire les visiteurs des jo lui son
truc ce ne sont pas les restaurants
traditionnels chinois le canard laqué ou
les crevettes au sel
nous sommes dans un des restaurants
c'est une franchise
chaque franchise à un thème différent
ici c'est le mexique
mais ce ne sont pas ces restaurants qui
l'ont rendu riche
il nous emmène à la sortie de pékin une
usine
sa fille travaille ici en père moderne
il l'a envoyé étudier aux états unis
elle revient tout juste de l'université
de los angeles pour travailler aux côtés
du directeur de l'usiné qu'il nous
présente
car son vrai secteur est industriel sa
fortune
il la doit à ce petit plat
le hamburger
il a eu l'idée de faire connaître le
hamburger ou chinois après l'ouverture
économique contrairement aux grandes
marques américaines il les produit en
usine sa recette les distribuer à
proximité des lieux de passage les
jeunes chinois en raffolent ils les
expédie dans 1800 points de vente dans
tout le pays et aujourd'hui encore ils
veillent au grain
[Musique]
tous les jours il faut nettoyer
lorsque vous changez de farine
c'est une habitude à prendre
et après cela deviendra un automatisme
d'accord
c'est très certainement la plus grande
usine de fabrique de hamburgers en chine
la capacité de production est de 60
milles à 70000 hamburgers par jour
et ses hamburgers vont tous après dans
les écoles les magasins les supermarchés
des hamburgers à réchauffer au micro
ondes il les propose aux écoliers comme
petit déjeuner ou au goûter succès
assuré
son quartier général
dc ils surveillent en permanence son
usine et ses 19 restaurants à son bureau
il préside également la fédération de
l'industrie et du commerce l'ouverture
de son pays il l'a vécue aux
avant-postes
en 1997 je suis allé effectuer une
visite aux états unis à la tête d'une
délégation de 50 personnes d'abattoirs
composé d'entrepreneurs chinois privé 1
du format mais
monsieur bush senior inviter mes deux
collègues et moi à déjeuner chez lui
bla bla vous voyez c'est son épouse
barbara bush
ils ont même dit que nous étions les
premiers chinois qui est mangé chez eux
[Musique]
il ya même sa signature
ah c'est un homme qui compte il a vite
compris qu'en chine il vaut mieux
s'occuper de politique si on veut
réussir dans les affaires il multiplie
les casquettes et collectionne les
laissez passer à la couleur rouge
conseil municipal l'assemblée nationale
réunie au gouvernementale
pour les hommes d'affaires chinois pour
je voulais faire du commerce va de pair
avec la politique d'asile on voit ici
il y a une relation très étroite entre
la vie politique et le commerce en chine
sont rondes ils ont qu'à d'autres
grottes england
d'après vous est ce que la chine est
toujours un pays communiste
bien sûr
[Musique]
est toujours un pays communiste
c'est juste que le communisme évolue
aussi avec le temps non avec les
changements économiques du pays witch
and kids zhang barn la chine met
l'accent sur le développement du pays
oui tiens
une chine toujours communiste peut être
avec des bémols une chose est sûre
aujourd'hui les milliardaires ne veulent
plus se mélanger avec les pauvres et des
pauvres à pékin on en trouve à chaque
coin de rue où loger lorsque l'on
cherche son confort
cet homme a trouvé une solution pour eux
ce promoteur de 36 ans connaît leurs
préoccupations il est millionnaire lui
aussi devant l'affluence de pékinois
fortunés il a décidé de les loger
ensemble dans un lotissement de riches
des châteaux individuels
comme des maisons préfabriquées
[Musique]
voici notre projet en développement
un parc résidentiel gigantesque
vous voyez chacune de ces maisons fait
en moyenne 1500 mètres carrés
vous avez vu le style principal est
européen
les maisons surtout sont de facture
plutôt française
voici le projet grandeur nature près de
l'aéroport
172 château pour millionnaires se
construisent les uns à côté des autres
le promoteur nous fait l'article
[Musique]
alors ici il y aura une salle de
réception de plus de 10 mille mètres
carrés
je pense qu'elle sera opérationnel dès
la fin de l'année prochaine
j'ai engagé un américain terminer ce
chantier ce sera une salle de réception
de luxe et privés bien sûr je pense
qu'elle sera la plus luxueuse de pékin
certains sont déjà vendus eli a même un
château témoins pour les visites et des
gardes factice
[Musique]
hot
on
[Musique]
et
on